these are the pictures Libyan medias as
show Russian mercenaries leaving
tripolis frontline they were meant to
shift the balance of power on the
battlefield in favor of Libyan warlord
halifa after but a series of defeats has
left after struggling to fulfill his
ambition to take the capital from
Libya's internationally recognized
government he's lost control of three
military camps an airbase in the West he
used to launch attacks on Tripoli and
several towns his forces are accused of
planting landmines in residential areas
putting civilians at risk during the
pullout as of yesterday we started
combing the liberated area to ensure the
safe return of everyone who was
displaced we are still closely
monitoring the movements of the remnant
militias and mercenaries who are trying
to reorganize their fragmented ranks we
are fully prepared to crush them
we assure our fellow Libyans in the
captured areas that we will not leave an
inch of the Libyan soil and will not
allow foreign mercenaries to bunker in
residential areas a leaked UN report
last month suggested after was backed by
up to one thousand and two hundred
mercenaries from Russia's Vagner Group a
private military contractor the UAE
which backs after is believed to be
bankrolling them the Kremlin and after
deny they were ever there the recent
military gains by government forces have
been largely possible because of turkeys
support it has sent troops to help
Tripoli against half-turns fighters
Ankara has been calling for a political
solution to the conflict and has refused
to bow to any pressure by the warlord
after the swift retreat on the
battlefield seems to suggest that when
time is fast shifting in his 13 month
long military campaign
I'm adapter do I hate al-jazeera my body
is a senior fellow at the Atlantic
Council with the research focus on Libya
he says the departure of the Russian
mercenaries is a major strategic blow
for hot tar why they've pulled out now
is subject to speculation obviously you
have to take into account that during
the past let's say weak turkey has
really upgraded aerial capabilities in
Libya and has significantly weakened the
strategic advantage that the Russian
mercenaries provided namely in in terms
of attacking aerial defense systems or
Panther systems that were a Marathi
supplied but Russian manufactured
systems now it's obvious that there is
some form of backdoor deal between
Turkey and Russia in terms of allowing
these mercenaries to back out of Tripoli
and go towards bonyadi then towards
Jaffa and perhaps out of Libya why they
did at this juncture I am not entirely
sure but if they hadn't withdrawn they
would have probably gotten killed and I
think that would have caused problematic
dynamics between Russia and Turkey since
late August it's actually the Russian
mercenaries that have been able the
ground offensive to not only continue
but for half Thor's tooth to actually
make a territorial headway so they
gained ground since then since then
because of the Russians involvement as
soon as they pulled out in roughly I
would say eight hours after loss the
territory that he's gained in eight
months that's how much of a strategic
military advantage these groups or the
Russian groups provided and now that
that doesn't mean that the war has ended
but it does mean that in terms of
capturing Tripoli let's say I don't
think that it's realistic to assume that
that will be possible if the let's say
backers of hopper do not significantly
escalate against Turkey it's also worth
noting that before pulling out they
significantly let's say put a a DS and
improvised explosive devices around
Tripoli which points to the fact that
they do not intend to be the attacking
force again because they'll be lets say
affected by their own minds that they
planted